This next story is just a funny one about
the highly triggerable nature of Donald Trump.
We've already done all the serious stuff related
to impeachment.
When will the trial be?
What happened?
What were the votes, what are the articles,
all that stuff you don't have.
Trump always wants to be the best at everything.
The most.
This the best that he has.
The biggest thing or whatever.
You know, Trump was impeached with more votes
against him than any previous president, and
this is particularly notable since there are
numerous vacancies in the house of representatives
right now.
We already talked about the big picture.
Trump is only the third president to be impeached.
Trump has been impeached by the most overwhelming
vote margin in the house of any other president,
which is hilarious.
Now, I want to be very clear.
The house was smaller when Andrew Johnson
was impeached, so by percentage, a higher
proportion voted to impeach Andrew Johnson
than Trump.
But in terms of sheer numbers, Clinton got
no more than 228 votes to impeach on either
article.
Andrew Johnson had one 26 in favor.
The house was smaller then, and Donald Trump
on the other hand had 230 and 229 in favor
of the impeachment.
Trump is the most impeached president in history.
Again, not the highest portion, but the highest
number, and of course, Trump tweeting this
morning in all caps.
Once again, the refrain presidential harassment.
Remember that back in 2014 when Barack Obama
was president, Donald Trump said he called
into Fox news and he said, listen, aside from
a conviction merely being impeached for a
president turns you into a mess.
Obama would be a mess under impeachment.
Obama would be thinking of nothing other than
impeachment.
This is Trump talking about this back in 2004
or what year?
2014 sorry.
Take a look.
Do you think Obama seriously wants to be impeached
and go through what what bill Clinton did?
He would be a mess.
He would be thinking about nothing, but it
would be a horror show for him.
It would be an absolute embarrassment.
It would go down on his record permanently,
but this thing, Oh, he'd love to be a peach.
That would be so good.
And the Republicans are all like, Oh, would
never have pictured, would never impeach him
because he liked that.
And the Republicans, and I'm a Republican.
As a Republican,
we have to assume that this is likewise a
horror show for Donald Trump.
An embarrassment for Donald Trump on Trump's
permanent record.
As he said, it would be on Barack Obama's.
But back to this story, this is why it matters.
I get it.
Trump was impeached with the largest number
of votes, but it was just over 50% of the
votes compared to the overwhelming percentage
that voted to impeach Andrew Johnson.
This is a reminder about the importance of
voting in the midterms.
Every vote for impeachment last night was
an election that was fought and won in the
midterms, right?
Dozens or more volunteers and staffers were
involved in each of those congressional elections
in the midterms of 2018 each vote is a congressional
district that Democrats won in 2018 this should
remind us how directly our effort during midterms
translates into real things in the real world.
So if you volunteered on a campaign in 2018
and that candidate won, you volunteered and
caused there to be 230 votes to impeach instead
of two 29 or two 29 instead of two 28 depending
on the article.
This stuff has real world impact and we need
to always remember this, especially in non
presidential election years.
In midterm years, we're turnout is often lower.
Engagement also tends to be much lower.
Every single one of those campaigns represents
one impeachment vote.
They are up for reelection every two years
in the house of representatives.
They're up again right now and there is no
greater reminder of the amount
importance of this and by the way, what's
going on with judges is another reminder,
but we'll talk about that right after this
next short break